(glass breaks)
(guys scream)
- Eduardo man, you
are so loco, man!
We need a crazy vato
like you in our gang.
With this bandana, I
welcome you to the gang.
- Yo, hold up.
- Okay.
- What's going on?
- Hey, Carlito.
I was just welcoming
Eduardo into the gang.
- Why?
Who he, what he did?
- He's crazy, man.
We were thinking that the
gang needs a crazy guy.
- Yeah man, this guy is loco.
Show him, Eduardo.
(glass breaks)
- Wow, loco!
(Eduardo groans)
That's loco.
- Loco, huh?
- No, I'm the loco
one in this game.
- What?
- Okay, okay, check this out.
Quack quack quack, I'm a duck.
- No, no, no.
- I'm a crazy duck.
- No Carlito, it's not
that kind of loco, okay.
That's more like zany or goofy.
- Yeah.
- It's the wrong kind of loco.
- You wanna see loco?
- Carlito, you're not crazy.
You're like the quiet one.
- I'm not quiet, I never
be caught being quiet.
In fact, I'm always
loud, check it. (groans)
- Okay, okay, that was weird.
Were you yelling?
- I show you loco right here,
right now in broad daylight, yo.
- Carlito, no Carlito.
- Pull up our pants, homes.
- I got Tilikum on my underwear,
that's the black fish.
I'm naked and I don't even care.
- Carlito, you gotta
pull 'em up, okay?
There's like children in
this neighborhood, okay?
- Okay, but check this out.
I got nine punch cards
from Fro-Yo Universe,
each with one stamp in it.
Every time I get a fro
yo, I get a new card.
- Carlito, that's just being
cavalier with your finances
instead of collecting
your free dessert.
I mean, that's not loco,
that's just like
financially irresponsible.
- I might not be loco,
but you know who is loco?
My friend, Mr. Basurahead.
- Just dumping garbage.
- Hi, I'm the most
loco person in here.
- Carlito, why
would you do that?
- Okay.
- Carlito.
Okay, Carlito, you don't
have to do this, okay?
It's not necessary,
you're not the loco one.
- Check this out.
(bottle thuds on head)
Yeah, I'm crazy,
I'm the loco one.
(groans)
- Carlito, please
don't do it again.
Carlito, stop.
- I'm in too deep.
- This is like watching the
British version of "The Office"
like it's funny, but awkward
and sad at the same time.
- Yes.
- Oh!
- Well,
I think I just proved this
bottle is unbreakable.
(glass shatters)
- Carlito, you're
embarrassing yourself.
- Look at this, you
know, what's loco?
- No, no, no Carlito, what
are you gonna do with that?
- I don't know, I'm
too crazy.(groans)
- Carlito, why would
you do that, man?
That was loco, but not
in an entertaining way.
- Okay.
- Carlito, put down the gun!
- Oh don't you fear, the
crazy, crazy one is here.
- Carlito, stop!
Don't toss the gun
around, Carlito.
- [Gang Member] Put
the gun down Carlito!
- Shouldn't have done that.
- Stop twirling it!
- Loco, loco, loco, where
does it stop, nobody knows.
(gun fires)
- (bleep) Carlito, you just
shot Eduardo in the head!
- Now I'm the most
loco in the gang?
- Yes Carlito, by
process of elimination,
you are the most loco
person in the gang.
- Yes.
(guys scream)
- He caught the
bullet in his teeth!
That's the most locoest
thing I've ever seen.
No, no, no Carlito.
(gun fires)